the White House budget director said
today there will be no bailout for
Puerto Rico after the president
suggested there might be the hurricane
death toll meanwhile more than doubled
overnight here's dr. Jon LaPook for two
weeks resident Nick Prouty has been
flying almost daily runs to pick up the
sick and drop off supplies the roads
impassable up there even now it's hard
to measure the staggering toll of the
hurricane where do these people go
there's absolutely nothing left these
houses are absolutely destroyed they're
in splinters many of the new deaths are
from the islands rural interior where
most people are still without water
without power and Aid is arriving very
slowly
estimates are it will take months to
restore electricity that's at odds with
the president's upbeat remark about
power to a selected crowd in a church
further inland we landed near a
Community Hospital in Utah though - the
respirators work with dwindling supplies
dr. Jose Villa Fania is struggling to
get help for his sickest patients as
winds stabilize them and try to transfer
them to a another hospital they are
dying in the other settings so they end
up dying either on the way to the
hospital elsewhere or in San Juan that's
it room
they're people who we haven't recovered
yet that are dead at their houses as
prowdy looks down he knows there's more
suffering than he can see we don't see
it because we can't get to those people
know what's going out to that we had
finding out who is that there who's
missing it literally it has to happen on
a door-to-door basis today Puerto Rico's
governor told me the rising toll
includes drownings that had not been
reported three deaths were from loss of
oxygen when the power went off Anthony
dr. Jon LaPook just back from Puerto
Rico Thanks